[Music]
so i don't want to assume here but uh
are you a ricky martin fan
i was until you became gay
i was when i was growing up but then
yeah he did become gay or not became but
then he came out gay
uh but yeah he was [ __ ] fine i mean
he's still very attractive so when he
came out you're like bart will do well i
was already older so he kind of was like
you kind of like ricky martin
yeah
were you his fan when he was in menudo
uh menudo was way before my time but
thank you no it's not no it's not it's
wrong
[Laughter]
class of 65
you were kids
but i heard
about his nephew yeah he's gay too [ __ ]
yeah listen to this yeah so recently
yeah
ricky martin uh was in a
lawsuit uh or pretty much was accused by
his nephew
of having a sexual relationship and then
harassing him afterwards
damn that's crazy
his nephew must be
how old was the nephew though when this
happened uh i believe i believe he is 21
years old oh we got what happened 21
year old nephew yeah
hey you don't even want to [ __ ] twins so
shut up yeah that's true
that's weird though that's weird that's
incest bro
it's gonna be twin brothers that's what
i [ __ ] up
oh nick's good with twin brothers no
that's still incest to me bro you know
what i mean but you said it was fun that
he's 21 so you're okay with it so maybe
no no i just thought like you know i
just want to see how good looking his
nephew is that's all so he's okay with
incest he's just not okay with
pedophilia is what it is
exactly yeah yeah yeah he's got to be
above 18 bro at least what if they're 18
in a different country where you know
with the tigers that's not up to me
that's not up to me that's up to their
government so he's not cool with
siblings but he's okay with
nephews
that are twenty-one
and over he said eighteen because
yesterday he was not cool with twitter
he was not cool with twins yeah this
whole is sweating so hard right now what
are your dark secrets did you piece of
[ __ ] dry dude come check them out drive
them hey do your first stand
take a whiff too nah so the nephew had
claimed that he and ricky had a seven
month sexual affair
and after it ended ricky began stalking
and harassing him
rickley uh ricky strongly denied the
allegations saying he never had a sexual
relationship with man and the singer's
legal team said that the nephew suffers
from mental issues and i think he first
found out because the nephew had
obtained a temporary restraining order
um but ricky and his team you know
weren't in court or anything so he
molested his down syndrome nephew that's
whoa
ricky martin could have any dude he
wants bro
you don't think so you don't think any
woman too man he's hot yeah bro he can
throw it down and he chooses his nephew
hey hey hey hey remember he's gay why
would he choose any woman that he wants
no she said that i said dude he could
have any duty the people who get uh
whatever attacked are always by people
who are the closest ones it's like
family members yeah that's true that's
true i found that out recently recently
in like a in this case so he's saying
that he got attacked but he's attacking
you know what i mean the nephew says
that ricky attacked him but i gotta
really
is attacking right but how good looking
is a nephew too because if he's uglier
than ricky martin i don't believe it let
me show you this and it's an easy
there's an easy way to figure it out
figure it out okay i'm what you call a
victim you you gotta have a lineup
of penises
right there we go ricky martens is one
of them
if the nephew can go
that one then we know that ricky martin
did the thing oh
oh [ __ ] this is just all allegations
yeah you're right this is the nephew
in case you were wondering oh she's
pretty nice hair she's pretty wait what
that sounds ugly dude no no no no
hey that's not ugly
ricky ricky martin compared to ricky
yeah but that's a professional photo
versus he ain't trying to touch that
though yeah but he didn't get a
professional photo
that's
[Laughter]
small asian [ __ ] the guy with the
cowboy boots and [ __ ] and the belt
buckle and the cowboy hat
you know what i mean
you know that was a big buckle too did
you see that he was like i thought he
liked william hung
does he because he did the song because
it's his most famous cover yeah
she bangs that's a ricky martin song
that's a william hung song
original
now it is well done william he outdid
ricky dude man did were you there when
we saw william hung at the restaurant
uh it was garden cafe right it was
garden yeah he was kind of a little this
one [ __ ] and [ __ ] alhambra right
here wait he was a dick
oh can we get a picture with you and
then the mom comes in no no no no
pictures no pictures oh i wasn't asking
you [ __ ] i was actually [ __ ] william
can i suck your dick right now bro yes
or no of course that looks weird man he
was very handsome
dude he is is william hung more handsome
than ricky martin's nephew oh
they're about to say they're about the
same man really
hey no disrespect is that how you feel
it's about the same yeah ballpark um i
just felt like he looked exactly the way
he does on tv in person so i wasn't
disappointed wait mom
yeah yeah yeah so but is he ugly or is
he good looking that fool looked like a
fish
he's accurate bro
is he ugly or is he good-looking
he's not someone's dick i want to suck
is that what you want to eat whoa hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa you married lady you
handling your boy real quick i just
asked people
hey my guy
hey my guy oh my god william is ugly as
[ __ ] he's not good that's his teeth is
rotty man hey listen you wallow dude
he's one of the most best looking guys
in [ __ ] asian celebrities celebrity
hey william hunger
huh
[Laughter]
who do i want to [ __ ] yeah
see me go simulator or william huh dude
come on easy
what's my answer
[Laughter]
hey william he got his proportions all
right he's hung hey you know what got
some short ass legs i don't like that
[ __ ] william hung probably got ass bro
he probably got some cheeks on him yo
he's got a badunka dunk now yeah does he
oh yeah dude when we saw him at the
restaurant that was extra thick yeah he
got something he got some thighs on him
you know you know he's a he's a
professional poker player and
motivational speaker now excuse me yeah
how do you know this i follow him we're
friends go to the seminars to follow
your dreams
dude we did karaoke together
and he invited himself on stephen
nicki's podcast what yeah so i'm coming
over
so what are we gonna do the podcast huh
that fool's teeth are crazy you know
like in the you know like in the cartoon
where the piano falls from the thing and
then the keys come up
his teeth
dude i've never like if you ever wanted
to frame that
piano drum
i want to see what an apple looks like
after he bites into it
if he bites into an apple you can
identify who he is immediately because
his teeth are [ __ ] crazy williams
teeth look like lychee seeds
it's [ __ ] clear and there's like a
black core on the inside for some reason
ain't no disrespect to him though but
when he's back hey we should be dunking
on ricky martin right now i'm italian i
just say a bunch of offensive [ __ ] and i
just go no
i learned about ricky martin because of
william that's tight dude i didn't know
ricky martin who's better looking he's
united william hung or jack ma
william hung yes i agree bro
he got his teeth now he actually he
actually looks good here i didn't see
that at garden cafe i got him cafe he
probably had his veneers out grills
what's up honestly grills jack ma looks
like a skinnier version of william hunt
yeah
jack ma looks like he's ate something
sour all the time you know what the only
reason why
jack ma's face looks like a saran
wrapped over some bones
like he just smushes his face against
the glass
at all times it just stayed that way oh
[ __ ]
jackpot's a [ __ ] gangster did you see
that speech that he made before he
disappeared where he was where a
reporter asked him
how do you feel about stealing other
people's brands and he goes well you
could sue me as much as you want i'll
just make more than you ever sue me for
yep yep that was pretty good and then he
made this face
then this face happened dude but this is
the face of a true gangster he said that
[ __ ] publicly that was [ __ ] dope
what's that called hat size man
[ __ ] eight and a half okay okay how
about this how about this
has she not reappeared yet
he did a little bit he did he's not dead
or anything like that
yeah he's he's just quiet
he hasn't done his shows though he's
been tranquil you know what i mean i
like his annual shows that he's nice
he's a docile member of the communist
party now you know
yeah but william did set asian people
back a little bit when he when he did
the little uh american idol thing
that [ __ ] got under my skin a little bit
really i thought it empowered me
of course you dude you're not getting
under your skin more than uh what's
what's that in the hangover when it
shows a little dick with all the people
that one got under my skin a little bit
i mean i think i feel like that set
asians back good amount here's the thing
about ken jong right and he's he did put
this out publicly he goes you know at
the time like would i do that now
absolutely not but his his his mentality
was that i i had to get my foot through
this door and then i'm gonna change it
later which he did so at least he
followed up with that much more than his
foot yes yeah he put his little dick
also at the same time he's a stand-up
comedian playing a role yeah william
hung is being himself and he's setting
people back right yeah i mean it's
different what's worse my buddy paul kim
when he went to american idol his
mission was to audition and do that [ __ ]
to erase what william hung did to asian
people
on that show did he sing ricky martin oh
let me tell you something he did and he
banged he banged
it was great but when he did that i
think for him like it was such a weird
setback for a lot of like asian dudes
who could sing who wanted i mean
filipino people they've been singing
forever yeah and i feel like that one
thing just erased all that [ __ ] kai
disappeared you know like oh
my god
you know
you